my name is Francois douches heh and I'm
CEO of Dalian Irene energy is a great
project of a customer of ours that we're
working with because in Africa there's a
real issue that between 600 million and
1 billion people don't have electricity
access Irene energy so an opportunity to
solve problems that energy service
providers are facing today because the
systems they are using are not easy to
adapt to the evolution of the energy
markets there were a number of technical
challenges
Danae we needed to tackle blockchain
involves cryptography it involves
private keys for doing cryptography and
the private keys are something that you
must absolutely keep private the way to
do it
the way it's been done by systems to
protect it really well up to now was to
use expensive hardware equipment
expensive hardware servers specifically
designed for protecting this this was
absolutely not fit for the project
because we're talking about specifically
a project that wants to lower the costs
of accessing electricity lowering the
cost of the technologies the back
offices that the energy service
providers use we found the right
solution in really next-gen technologies
next-gen technologies that IBM provides
I'm talking about IBM Cloud Data shield
and was blast really it also provides
scalability because it's based on the
IBM kubernetes service it's a very nice
feeling because that shows that IBM
really cares about what's going on in
the field they're not simply addressing
large companies with a project that are
gonna take years to to be put on no they
want to address real concerns with real
solutions and actually real disruptive
solutions and that was exactly why we
were looking for
[Music]